good evening welcome to this evenings
program Josiah bunting the third is
president of the Harry Frank Guggenheim
Foundation in New York City before
taking up his duties at the foundation
he served as superintendent of his alma
mater the Virginia Military Institute in
Lexington Virginia among general
buntings books is a biography written
for Arthur Schlesinger presidential
series on ulysses s grant he is
currently completing a biography of
george c marshall army chief of staff
during World War Two secretary of state
from 1947 249 and secretary of defense
from 1952 1951 he is married to the
former Diana Margaret Cunningham they
have four children and four
grandchildren they live on a farm in
Fauquier County Virginia please welcome
Josiah bunting
thank you very much and I'm fighting
sort of a bad throat so i hope you will
bear with me a little bit before coming
down here I was looking at Fox News if
you are not on the road that much and
you're staying in a nice hotel you tend
to watch television most of what i saw
this afternoon was about the abdominal
muscle americans have a great fixation
on abs are you like that sculpt the ABS
of your dreams I heard Brown University
quote for bids and will punish any
speech that makes someone else feel
angry impotent disfranchised or with
bruise self-esteem another college
forbids explicitly elevator eyes I I
guess that means if you're looking at a
member of the other gender and you look
up and down that's elevator eyes that's
a thought that would be amusing to
people at hillsdale this is a this is a
lovely college and it's a pleasure to be
on a campus like this where people know
what their business is where they seem
to like each other in a place which is
obviously flourishing either friend
David Riesman who was a sociologist who
died about 10 years ago he said the
great colleges are places that have a
very fierce sense of their own identity
and that what makes the education that
is offered by the faculty and the books
and the laboratories in those colleges
what makes it stick to the ribs is their
consciousness that they are members of
an elite tough challenging place and
when I heard dr. Ahrens a recital of
some of those numbers last night that is
the obviously irrefutable testimony to
the success of hillsdale doing what it
believes in and doing it well in making
no
oh jeez places like this are to be
cherished and there are relatively few
of them in the United States so we are
all privileged to be here this evening
I'm going to talk about the classics but
in a way which I hope will not induce
sleep too quickly and I want to talk in
particular about the role of classics in
not only classics of history but other
forms of classics and educating young
people a common story we are members of
a small Midwestern church in a town like
the town in the movie Hoosiers which
ESPN said is the best sports movie ever
made a town like Hillsdale a man of 87
has just died a man born in our town and
who will time out for three years in the
Army and four years at the state
university has never left the town he
has raised his children here he and his
wife have been married 50 for years they
have 12 grandchildren he has run the
state farm agency for 40 years and is
quietly active in civic life he is not a
political activist he is not a political
hater and is inclined to say of whoever
happens to be president quote oh I don't
know that's a heck of a job and he's
probably doing the best he can unquote
that kind of person his best friend
gives the eulogy and when the frame
comes to a brief part in the middle
where he says John served in the Army
and the Second World War and landed on
Normandy on the afternoon of d-day and
was wounded and was awarded the Bronze
Star you suddenly notice many people in
the church are suddenly whispering to
each other and what are they saying I
never knew that
you never knew that because he never
told you he did what he was asked to do
by his country what he normally says is
I was in the service and the last three
words of the phrase are assumed the
service of my country excuse me st.
Francis is remembered for many things
one of them his observation that I am
always praying and sometimes I even use
words he means that the power of human
example is by far the most potent of
inspiration and evangelism lessons
guides to us and for an eager those
small cohort of American students and
citizens the study of our national
history furnishes the most fertile
source of moral examples examples of
human conduct at its most ignoble and at
its most sublime and this is an
important reason that young people
should study history although not the
only one if you have a child four or
five or six years old who shows signs of
early musical interest and aptitude and
you arrange piano lessons for her be
discerning in your selection of her
teacher asked the teacher what early
simple compositions she proposes to use
in the little girls training the answer
you want is a Bach Mozart Beethoven
Schumann the point is to begin the
child's training on simple but exquisite
classical compositions by those we call
the Masters no pablum no made up little
songs and pieces about birds animals and
toys it trips to the zoo the same way in
first year Latin in high school put
simple compositions by good writers and
historians in front of your students no
stories written in two
five called Cornelia in the kitchen or
farming on my summer holiday and when
you introduce your children to history
and imaginative literature do it the way
your great-great grandparents did in the
last quarter of the 19th century read to
them at night in the living room from
James Fenimore Cooper Herman Melville
Francis Parkman Admiral Morrison moving
along to our own generation from David
McCullough zone mentor Bruce Catton or
from Douglas salvo Freeman read them a
good life of Churchill or a good life of
Lincoln read them the last part of
General Lee's farewell to the Army of
Northern Virginia right after Appomattox
you will take with you the satisfaction
that proceeds from the consciousness of
duty faithfully performed children need
to hear things like that when they are
very young and if you stress them they
learn them and they subsist on them for
a lifetime incidentally that particular
sentence our own time nearest needs to
hear that the satisfaction that proceeds
from duty faithfully performed no Oprah
no lexus no people magazine excuse me no
book contract just the satisfaction that
you did your duty properly read them
these lines from the greatest political
history ever written quote we say a man
without political business is a man with
no business at all or restraint
impresses men most or you have not yet
begun to consider what sorts of people
are these Athenians whom you may have to
fight the head of every democracy that
goes to war that initiates a war
particularly should think very seriously
about those lines what is the nature of
our adversary
these men who love their city and its
heritage so much they were thereafter
ashamed to fall beneath a certain
standard tell them the story of the
citizens of Barry in England the you are
why Barry in 1919 the mayor and several
other citizens went to Kemal atatürk
then the president of Turkey and said we
proposed to erect a small monument on
the beach at Gallipoli where many of our
sons have died in the British Army units
that go into combat typically are all
from the same place so that when there
is a devastating tactical defeat and
losses are enormous they saw Ataturk and
he said I would be pleased and proud to
permit this provided you allow me to
write their epitaph Winston Churchill
said magnanimity is the greatest of
virtues and next to courage and that is
the kind of magnanimity a story like
that which lodges in the memory of young
people and they can feed off it for the
next 70 or 80 years having shed their
blood here they have become my son's
also
as lineal descendants of Tocqueville
Americans of 1832 very little has
changed in our national character and we
shift uneasily in our seats when we hear
the word classic we think of horrible
childhood summers when we were made to
read boring books from the library with
titles like the House of the Seven
Gables or the rise of Silas Lapham but
when i say classic i mean a human
artifact a work of human creation which
is spoken directly and movingly to 5 or
10 or 30 or 50 generations when Colin
Firth finally recites the king's speech
in that wonderful movie it is inflected
with the Adagio from Beethoven's seventh
Symphony and when he leaves the studio
to greet his friend the actor Geoffrey
Rush the director marks the warmth of
his reception with a wonderful
introductory phrases of the Beethoven
Emperor piano concerto these are musical
compositions 250 years old and they are
as apt as exquisite as anything that
could be created today perhaps more so
when Hamlet wanders about when Hamlet
wanders about the business of an army
that he sees in the distance and it's
explained to him that the Army is under
the command of Fortinbras a Norwegian he
wonders aloud excuse me and reflects
that he sees in his mind the imminent
deaths of 20,000 men that for a fantasy
and a trick of fate go to their graves
like beds fight for a plot which is not
to enough and continent to hide the
slain they're going off to fight for
place there won't make a cemetery big
enough to hold them all those kinds of
classical metaphors which lad them lodge
themselves in the minds of ardent young
students it seems to me are a large part
of your business
start them doing it when they are six or
eight do not wait for them to be exposed
excuse me for ulterior purposes by AP
United States history where they will
believe they must learn everything there
is to know about Jay's treaty or the
establishment Arian flaws in article 2
of the Constitution or if there are
hidden signs of racism in the young
Abraham Lincoln remember seriously the
counsel of a famous Renaissance
philosopher each night upon retiring
require yourself to learn and memorize
something exquisite and call yourself to
account for it in the morning it may
sound idle to you but consider this
homely but charming anecdote in 1943
Franklin Roosevelt with his friend Harry
Hopkins and the Prime Minister Winston
Churchill are being driven from
Washington who was what was then called
shangri-la we now know it is Camp David
not far from frederick maryland again
excuse me I'm so sorry they saw a sign
marking a small restaurant named for
Barbara fritsche a union heroine shoot
if you must this old gray head but spare
your country's flag she said looking
from her window at the lawn ragged gray
lines following General Jackson into
Maryland instantly Churchill sitting in
the back seat recited the entire poem
again excuse me all 12 verses he had
done the same thing at the age of 11
when it was a first-year school boy at
Harrow all of McCauley's lays of ancient
Rome to prove that he was not so dumb as
the headmaster might have thought that
he was how can man die better than
facing fearful odds for the
Russia's of his father in the temples of
his gods before you retire this evening
require yourself to reread Lincoln's
second inaugural address the long and
infinitely complicated in beautiful
penultimate paragraph a meditation on
the question of theodicy and omnipotent
and infinitely good Creator has given or
has permitted to exist for four years a
war of unspeakable horror and suffering
how are we to explain this Lincoln asks
his audience all of them know their
Bible as we allow that these judgments
of the Lord are true and righteous
together and talking about the proper
and appropriate furniture for the minds
and memories of Americans beginning when
they are young and when their minds and
imaginations are such creations of such
creations passions classics as are
incarnated in the adults who have
learned them and that they see all the
time if you are 50 or 60 years old or
thereabouts-- plus or minus a few years
and you went to a good college and were
made to study the history of our country
and not given a choice among 450
so-called distribution requirements if
you were the beneficiary of such good
fortune your text was likely called the
growth of the American Republic it was
written by Henry Steele kommadeur and
Admiral Samuel Elliott Morrison the
section on the revolution in the
founding is very powerful and kommadeur
made a particular study of the period
asking the ageless question how did it
happen that in the last 25 years of the
18th century in North America a republic
was conceived brought into being
successfully defended and established in
a way
that time has now proved to be the
greatest Democratic Republic or human
polity that has ever existed in the
world why and how was that why was that
in the spring of 1789 when we were a
country of 2.8 million citizens when the
first administration assumed office in
New York it comprised Washington Adams
Jefferson Hamilton and Henry Knox
Benjamin Franklin still down the road 90
miles away able to give counsel Madison
the presiding presence in the House of
Representatives Samuel Adams Jon Jay etc
etc the historian kommadeur accounting
for or laboring to account for the this
fluorescence of this kind of talent and
accomplishment at this time in our
history offers examples of similar
phenomena and other times and places he
talks about 5th century Athens which
then had less than 25,000 citizens he
talked about 18th century Vienna the
venue of Haydn Mozart and Beethoven and
their successors a flock of successors
and interestingly so many of the great
greatest interpreters of those wonderful
German composers today seem to be Asians
if you look at the most of the major
symphony orchestras at least the ones I
know in this country Asian violinist
jealous are popular are populated all
out of proportion it seems to me to
their percentage of the population isn't
that an odd and beautiful and
interesting tribute to what happened in
eighteenth-century Vienna he writes
about the Copenhagen of Hans Christian
Andersen the England of Elizabeth of
Marlo and Shakespeare we are in the
realm of what is called prosopagnosia
the study of different groups of people
who come together in a common time for a
common purpose but to kommadeur excuse
me the most interesting and the most
astonishing of these cohort
is that of the American founders in
writing in 1960 during the time of a
presidential election campaign and NSA
well well known he found himself growing
rather bored by conversations he kept
bumping into which asked this question
why were the founders so good and look
what we have running for public office
today how can i account for it well
kommadeur of course acknowledged the
role of chance being born at the right
time of large challenges that present
themselves at infrequent intervals but
unpredictable intervals we cannot select
the year and the circumstances of our
own birth but for the generation of
Americans born between 1730 and 1760 and
born into circumstances which permitted
exposure to schooling and into homes in
which reading and study were valued and
in the colonies along the eastern
seaboard especially Virginia
Massachusetts Pennsylvania plainly it
was in the character of the way they
were educated and prepared for their
challenges and opportunities that suited
them to their tasks how did they read
and study and with what conscious aims
what were they asked to read Charles de
Gaulle once received the prize as a
cadet at sancere for the proved ability
to sit for a long time and study and
think about a single thing resisting
fatigue on the long New England evenings
they fastened on history especially that
of ancient Rome and Greece and on
history as a teacher of moral lessons to
those for whom obligations of
citizenship and leadership were primary
they read Plutarch the red Tacitus they
read Cicero they read the Stoics they
read about heroes who always exalted the
right over the blandishments of Fame or
riches John Adams acknowledged only
posthumous regard as an appropriate goat
or a spur to a proper American citizen
nothing else could be admitted a
Washington Hamilton Madison John J
George Mason we might say the same the
study of history in a political
philosophy these were the elements of
their education great and enormous
challenges the challenges met these were
also people of astonishing versatility
they did it all and they didn't make
much distinction between all of the
components of the all like the Nike shoe
commercial they just did it they wrote
their own public papers they wrote far
better than we do they felt more clearly
than we they believed profoundly in
emulation you study Pericles with a
conscious aim of getting his qualities
into your own character they prized
disinterestedness that is to say
consciously thinking about things
without reference to how they thought
might without reference to their own
prejudices and how they influenced how
they thought they paid only modest
attention interestingly to their health
David McCullough points out that so many
of these revolutionary heroes lived into
a advanced old age like Symphony
conductors think about that a little bit
later when you leave they paid only
modest attention to the health above all
they knew that learning the lessons of
history was without full value unless
you have the character
and the discernment to employ those
lessons now this is very important
people talk about the lessons of history
the lessons of history that you imbibe
may be wrong although the better you are
educated in the more you think about
them the more likely it is they will be
right but the hard part comes in the
implementation of the lesson the lessons
and that is an altogether different
thing than it is the brave man chooses
while the coward turns aside till the
multitude make virtue of the faith they
had denied that beautiful old poem made
into him James Russell Lowell recently
thrown out by the authorities of the
Episcopal Church as being too were like
incidentally I mentioned 19 1832 that
was an interesting year with regard to
the revolution dr. aren mentioned that
year last night that was here the death
of the only Catholic signer of the
Declaration Charles Carroll of Maryland
Lincoln vividly remembered that and the
thrill of horror and grief that swept
through the country and Tocqueville
noted it we had lost physical touch at
last with that generation Americans were
very conscious of that at that time Paul
Johnson a great British historian extols
a successor generation his generation
that he places next to the founders in
point of talent and accomplishment was a
generation born in the last quarter
excuse me of the 19th century for the
military and naval great ones of the
Second World War generals and admirals
who would be men in their 50s and 60s
during that time the leaders of the
great greatest generation for these
people growing up in those years a
lifetime immersion in history would seem
to have been standard in astonishing the
large percentage of these men grew up on
farms in the American Outback there has
never been a military caste in our
country the way there is for example in
Germany or in Great Britain but there
has always been ambition for improvement
and for many such youngsters West Point
and Annapolis have been their way out of
Dodge the Nimitz Eisenhower Omar Bradley
contemporaries of Harry Truman's
incidentally these were all lifetime
students of history and especially of
military history now neglected and even
shunned by universities once at the very
heart of the education of people who
would serve in wartime very much ignored
also in high schools and in graduate
schools if you find pancreatic cancer an
unpleasant topic why not abandon the
study of it if you find war and
unpleasant topic by all means stop
looking at it invariably historical
narrative and military history separates
those who have conducted themselves
ignoble II from those we used to call
heroes and invariably our minds are
populated with vivid examples inspiring
or incarnated warnings of conduct that
is base a peculiarities of the military
profession for those who make it a
career is that it must be learned for
the most high most part in peacetime we
cannot know who is going to be an
inspired and a gifted military leader
until he or nowadays she is tested in
battle but military history and its
study can at least help us in the
training and preparation and education
of those who would follow that
profession no profession seems to rely
less in finding and recognizing talent
for leadership than academic success
if you read biographies of famous
soldiers and Americans love to read
those books even though most
universities don't teach them walk into
barnes and noble any saturday morning
and there is a the rug is worn thin but
the people running up to get books about
retired generals great generals and one
of the things that is so interesting
about most of these people and you can
predict this in almost every book is
that in the second chapter which is
usually called boyhood or something like
that there is an opening participial
phrase usually in the second paragraph
although a mediocre student at west
point comma although a mediocre student
at west point comma there are only two
exceptions to that one was Lee who was
the number two man in his class of 1829
and the other was Douglas MacArthur who
graduated at the head of his class in
1903 the point is not that Ulysses Grant
was a dumbbell the point was frankly and
i taught at West Point for a while a lot
of the bright ones are bored and they
don't want to study that stuff and they
look out the window or they read
something that has not been assigned and
then suddenly when they're about 35 or
40 bingo their number one in their class
at Fort Leavenworth in two or three
years later their commanding a division
the linkage between military success and
academic success is very very frail
Johnson is talking about the generation
of Eisenhower MacArthur Marshall Nimitz
Halsey Spruance this was a generation as
I said earlier raised mainly in the
outback not privileged to boy hoods
Eisenhower of course classic son of the
hardscrabble boyhood all of them readers
of history as young men and here's the
interesting thing most of them were born
at a time when they were being taught by
veterans of the Civil War who were still
relatively young people if like Douglas
MacArthur or George Marshall you were
born
in 1880 and you were a 12 years school
12 year old school boy in the early
1890s you had teachers who were still on
the right side of 50 who had fought at
Shiloh or Gettysburg so you had a direct
link with the great ones who had
participated in that way they grew up in
families in which parents read to them
usually from history at night and from
important works of literature and
history President Roosevelt used
Eisenhower as a guide when he was shown
the ancient battlefield of Carthage near
a major North African battle where
American soldiers had been fighting the
Germans marshal perform the same office
for others that he escorted someone said
how do you know all of this he said I
read all of GA NT when I was a boy my
parents read made made me read all of
those books G a hint he was a famous
writer of military classical and
medieval works about war the most
popular classical history writer of
historical novels of the day the most
famous of which published in the late
1870s was than her a story of the christ
one of the three bestsellers of the
second half of the 19th century you can
probably get Uncle Tom Uncle Tom's Cabin
would you want to go for a trifecta
anybody the memoirs of ulysses s grant
sold more than 2 million copies an
enormous bestseller Mark Twain was the
as it were Midwife and publisher he
profited handsomely from the sale of the
book and they sold it door-to-door to
all veterans of the Union Army how can
you be without the memoirs of the great
general grant Oh certainly can't let me
get my pen
and in 1895 Mark Twain gave mrs. grant
Julia a check for two hundred thousand
dollars and I have no idea what that
must have been worth in 1895 the point
is that the presumption still held you
read history especially the histories of
War diplomacy and politics of
statesmanship and the early years of the
American Republic in your red with a
conscious intent of improving but to
know more and for pleasure and again to
populate your minds and memories with
war with men and heroes who have
deserved well of the country in 1947
George Marshall who was Secretary of
State was sitting on the platform with
the President of Princeton University on
the occasion of celebrating the 200th
anniversary of that University he
remarked to the president looks like all
of the students had been in the army and
of course they were they were GI Bill
graduates what made Marshall say that
the president asked he said they're all
wearing khaki pants that's where that
started and you can walk into any men's
store in the United States and all 20
year old boys on their way to college
probably here at Hillsdale are still
wearing khaki pants that's where that
started the prominent members of Paul
Johnson's leaders of the post-war era
prominently included along with Marshall
and this is the second half of Johnson's
Great cohort a great son of Michigan and
I earnestly hope that when you hear his
name there will be a yup of delighted
recognition he is one of the great
forgotten on Americans of the last
century right up there with people like
Henry Stimson and Elihu route Arthur
Vandenberg I hope he is remembered
affectionately in this state it was
pride and particularly in his hometown
of Grand Rapids where he was editor of
the paper he went to Washington
he became President Pro Tem of the
Senate head of the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee and working with
Harry Truman formed such a partnership
of bipartisanship that was more
responsible than anything else working
with Marshall and others in charting and
implementing the most prolific and
successful and admirable period in the
formation of foreign policy in our
national history nineteen forty five to
nineteen fifty extraordinary the
Marshall Plan NATO the Western alliance
the Berlin Airlift the recognition of
Israel this was a time of enormously
prodigal achievement these men Marshall
in the State Department and others who
work for him 10 or 15 years younger
interesting interestingly we're all
products of a very different form of
Education and I'll touch on it briefly
because my time is limited but so many
of us curl our upper lip if we are
Midwesterners or if we live in the south
when we hear names like brown and
columbia and harvard and princeton and
williams and those kinds of places which
are sort of wimpy and excessively
liberal and a bad form of liberalism the
kind of liberalism which stands
liberalism on its head John stubbe John
Stuart Mill said there can be no
philosophy where fear of consequences is
greater than love of truth and if you
are a young professor making your way on
the faculty of one of those places and
you let slip that you like Edmund Burke
or Aristotle or perhaps even voted for
George Bush you will not receive tenure
think about the horror of that
everything a university should not be is
represented in that kind of climate
however the universities which furnished
most of the graduates that worked for
Truman at that time were very different
until about nineteen fifty
they were nurseries of active and
aggressive American patriotism just walk
around the campus of Harvard look at the
chapel at Princeton or at Columbia these
were the first people to join up in 1917
they couldn't wait to serve and not only
to serve but to go in the in the
dangerous places of the field everybody
who worked in the Department of State
under marshal just like everybody who
had worked as a civilian in the
department of war under henry stimson
had served in world war one robert
lovett who became deputy secretary of
defense in 1951 one the Navy Cross
flying one of those so called airplanes
in 1917 you were dealing with an
entirely different phenomenon in those
days if you were born into American
privilege you owe the country and you
freely an enthusiastic enthusiastically
acknowledged your debt Citadel's of
American patriotism this is the
Princeton of John Witherspoon it's the
Princeton also of Don Rumsfeld who in
1954 graduated from the University and
came back in the year two thousand and
four and told the graduates that in his
class 550 people out of a class of a
thousand had gone into the military not
for a career but for two or three years
it was the kind of thing you did you
owed if you wanted the elective
franchise in colonial Maryland you had
to be in the militia first well there
was this also speaking at this 200th
anniversary the Secretary of State told
the undergraduates that he could not
imagine they're leaving the university
without having studied and carefully
reviewed in their minds the long
Twilight Struggle between democratic
Athens and authoritarian Sparta he could
not imagine someone leaving without
having mastered that great book the
Peloponnesian War this must have
the faculty to hear this person say that
and must have confused the alot of the
people about to graduate he turned aside
the old argument that the study of
history was principally important as
instruction in the character of human
affairs of course it was this Marshall
said but much more important it puts
fire into the convictions about what is
needed and what it is right to do it
puts fire into the convictions he spoken
the same spirit Pericles addressed
Athenians gathered for the public
funeral of citizens killed in the first
year of the war against Sparta here
simply is the sustaining inspiration of
classical history well does this mean
that we are to be and to become
historical chauvinists citizens who
simply appropriate from history whatever
suits us our biases and our prejudices
no emphatically not if anything it
should immunize us against the
simple-minded embrace of examples we
find simply to make points the troubles
of our proud and angry dust said
Houseman are from eternity and shall not
fail we hope to earn an American
historian wrote 40 years ago and I think
this is a wonderful analogy we hope to
earn a habit of mind a way of thinking
what Victor Davis Hanson calls
safrussani a certain poise of thought a
balanced way of looking at things and
intellectual patients that might be
compared to the practical wisdom of a
general practitioner of Medicine who has
spent a lifetime watching listening
judging testing observing the skill of
an old country doctor a diagnostic skill
for after all if we study history only
to satisfy an itch or a curiosity it
will no sense that we will use what
we're to learn we really are not
historians at all we are simply
antiquarians I have the sense that
Hillsdale believes these things in his
heart we are so fortunate to be here
thank you all very much
he'll know the Florida questions well
that seems to have taken care of all the
questions the fort benning they say is
there any questions yes sir well thank
you for your presentation general i
recently read education of a general the
biography of marshall 1882 1932 i
believe of us understand that's one of
your projects could you tell us how
you're going to your perspective and
what you're going to do with that
particular work yes I was warned i work
in New York City and occasionally I go
to dinners and I was warned that if you
ever find yourself acting as an MC and
Henry Kissinger as the speaker don't
ever call for questions because you will
be there until the quarter of two and
i'm going to try to do this in about 90
90 seconds and if my wife were here she
wouldn't even give me 90 s and 90
seconds marshall is an artifact of his
own conscious creation starting at about
age 15 very Victorian person i am going
to be a certain way he was attracted to
the military profession basically
through his great uncle who was one of
Lee's aids and he is one of those people
who came along at the right time but who
was uniquely equipped to take advantage
of what he had learned went to the
Philippines when he was very young got
his big break in world war one served
with john pershing he had developed a
reputation for intellectual rectitude
and proficiency which was astounding he
was very quiet he was very calm he made
his way strictly through military
efficiency but every now and then would
do something that was so astounding
people could not believe it I'll give
you one quick example
September 1917 he's at the First
Division Headquarters John Pershing
comes down to talk to the officers
Pershing has just seen the officers put
on a demonstration of a battalion attack
against a trench when the demonstration
is over Pershing turns to the general
and all of the officers and Pershing was
a man of a Titanic presence he was the
most formidable and scary person you and
I have ever met I'm disgusted with what
I have seen I'm embarrass and I'm
ashamed to be in the same army with you
this is the worst demonstration of its
kind I have if I have ever seen stares
at them for a while and then turns to
walk away just a minute General Pershing
there's something that needs to be said
here and since nobody else is I suppose
I should who are you major marshal sir
operations officer for the next five
minutes Marshall lets loose a fusillade
of data demonstrating to Pershing why
the demonstration has gone awry the
division has marched all night long
they've had no time for rehearsal they'd
never been asked etc etc all of it very
compelling evidence he finishes Pershing
nods and then turns to walk towards his
limousine Marshall lays a hand on the
forearm of the great man the horrific
thing all of these officers watching
this I'm not finished
and then goes on for another two or
three minutes and purging by this time
it was really nonplussed says well you
know we have a lot of problems in
headquarters also and I understand that
all of us have many challenges we have
to overcome a marshal says that's true
but we have to finish hours every night
before we retire Pershing gets into the
limousine drives away general cyber
comes puts his arm around him everybody
gathers around good luck in Guam or
Alaska two weeks later Pershing comes
down and thereafter whenever he arrives
he has to see Marshall and within six
months he has made Marshall chief
operations officer of the first Army and
at the end of the war he asked Marshall
to be his aide to camp so Marshall
spends the next five years working
directly for Pershing in Washington
basically learning Pershing and the
whole army but also the Congressional
etc etc now fast forward just very
briefly and I will make this very short
in 1938 he attends a meeting in the Oval
Office with President Roosevelt there
are 13 people present the Secretary of
War the Secretary of the Navy Brigadier
General so and so he is by far the most
junior officer he's a brand new
Brigadier a deputy chief of staff and
Roosevelt says the kind of thing that a
lot of Americans were thinking in 1938
when we were descending into something
horrible we weren't certain what it was
but many of us felt that what was coming
would not end somehow without without
our participation Roosevelt's idea was
instantly to order the construction of
10,000 warplanes that's what they used
to be called we need 10,000 warplanes
right away these warplanes like a good
Navy are inherently defensive and they
will serve as a deterrent we will not
have to worry about Hitler chorus at
that time France was had not
olin and he finishes and then he says
quietly everybody agree with that what
about You general Marshall what about
you George what do you have to say I
don't agree with you at all mr.
president I think that's a bad idea same
scene everybody leaves good luck on Guam
so on two days later Harry Hopkins who
works for Roosevelt calls marshal up and
says the president would like to talk to
you some more about your views of how
these things might be done in about six
months later this interesting fellow
Hopkins a pretty close to a socialist
very left-wing bete noire of most most
most of us but he was very close to
Roosevelt and he said to Roosevelt war
is probably coming in to run the army
you need this man he said something like
you Franklin and the way you are you
need someone like this he is rigid he is
Orthodox he is brilliant he is austere
he is cold he tells the exact truth he
pulls no punches but he's as good as as
it gets Roosevelt reaches over 34 senior
generals mix martial head of the army
and Marshall and Roosevelt together for
the next five and a half for six years
are responsible for selecting the most
extraordinary array of talent we have
ever had in the American armed forces
including the Civil War we go to war at
the beginning with Mark Clark Omar
Bradley dwight d eisenhower spruance
Nimitz Halsey just a galaxy and Marshall
had been watching all these people in
the 20s and the 30s when they stayed in
uniform and didn't get out to try to
make a million bucks you want to see the
definitive gloss on this subject go see
the movie the Caine Mutiny it's about 40
years old and there's a scene at the end
in which they talk about what we were
talking about right now so that was
Marshall at his very best and then he's
brought into the state department
at that time when our affection which
was quite serious 1946 for the Soviet
Union was dissipating there were no
longer a country that lost 25 million
killed and there were our allies and
Life magazine had pictures of a guy
named Joe and the cover picture of
Stalin we were actually at that point
many of us not me not you but a lot of
people Marshall become Secretary of
State at a time to restore some order to
the State Department and it inaugurates
this extraordinarily productive period
tonight that I talked about earlier very
difficult person to get to know thank
God that people in those days rote rote
long letters I don't know what I don't
know what the historians are going to do
50 years from now this is where they let
it hang out they wrote long beautiful
rather tender letters to each other they
just as a last gloss on Marshall in that
group they also had and did not
apologize for leisure there was no cult
of visible busy-ness they had leisure
they went to school they taught they
thought about their profession they
thought seriously as early as 1925 that
the United States would be involved as a
member of a coalition in a war against
against the what became the Axis powers
there's one last chapter in Marshall's
life in that was of course Korea and the
whole MacArthur uproar and maybe some
time when we have three or four days we
can talk about that I will say this
about that relationship people impute a
rivalry between macarthur and marshall
George Marshall did not do rivalry this
was a sort of a Marcus Aurelius type of
person and when at the end of the war
all of these fellows were asked to cash
in right right there right there memoirs
18 members of the second Bush
administration of already written or are
writing books about their time Marshall
was offered a million dollars by bennett
cerf for his memoirs
I've already been adequately compensated
by my country see you later now where
has that gone and besides if I undertook
to do it seriously I would no doubt give
pain to the families of men no longer
living who have deserved well of the
country you know this is why this
greatest generation but also the
leadership Kadri of this generation our
kids need to know about that let me
mention one last name to you Pershing I
don't think most intelligent American
high school students have any idea who
Pershing was we have to keep alive the
active memory of these people and
populate the memories of our kids with
them you know yes ma'am
yeah one no question yes sir Thank You
Jennifer Jennifer wonderful talk I wish
you would address a little bit MacArthur
as well first of all his early education
which is also steeped in the classics
but I also remember his spending some
time in the West yes and then also
addressing what he did at West Point
when he was commandant there you know
MacArthur is an extraordinary American
extraordinarily accomplished
extraordinarily complicated like robert
e lee who who made his career as a
professional soldier he then becomes
president of a college and is what we
would almost call a progressive liberal
enlightened person when he runs the
college and Douglas MacArthur is
essentially the proconsul of Japan
revealed extraordinary talents as a
civic leader of the country which was
gradually being converted into a
functioning democracy he was a man of
extraordinary ability there was no
question about it with the exception of
Admiral King he was easily our best
strategist in World War two King and
MacArthur basically conceived the whole
strategy which we began to implement at
Guadalcanal in 1942 moving up New Guinea
and all of that there's no question that
there was nobody nobody could hold a
candle to him in the army in that regard
as a leader capable of inspiring fusing
together an army under terrible
circumstances and indeed a whole country
he was superb so he was the best there
was at West Point his career was very
famous his father had won the
Congressional Medal of Honor on
Missionary Ridge at the age of 19 so
that's pretty good inspiration he
graduated at the head of his class at
West Point his mother lived in the
Thayer
tell less than half a mile from the
barracks at West Point the whole time he
was a cadet and sort of let it be known
that mrs. McArthur around not taking
anything away from General MacArthur in
World War one his behavior was a little
bit like patents behavior in World War
two he was a daredevil he was physically
extremely and famously brave very
ambition he ran afoul of Pershing who
was quite Orthodox he warped bizarre
costumes when he went into combat he
wore a muffler and took the grommet out
of his hat that kind of thing but by far
the best decorated of all of our
soldiers in France he was a division
chief of staff when it ended and a
brigade commander he then went to West
Point and determined to shake the
institution up and to make people study
politics and economics as well as fluid
mechanics in calculus he worshipped at
the great cult of football the whole
time he was on Bataan he was getting
telegrams from Coach red Blake his
friend he was really into that so all of
those things were to the good the
problem was he was not very good at
reading other people who were smart and
who had useful things to say that did
not agree with his own things he
suffered the way many generals do from
for what Marshall called no colitis he
did not agree with the predominantly
European strategy of the Roosevelt
administration he wanted everything sent
up to help him and at the end you're
faced with or forced to confront a kind
of a conundrum and that is that although
his leadership in Korea during the nine
months that he was commanding in the Far
East was enlightened and and brilliant
particularly up
incheon no matter if as a strategist you
are Napoleon Bonaparte or Alexander the
Great you cannot continue to publicly
attack and denigrate and disagree with a
constituted civil authority of the
country my first boyhood memory is the
Truman MacArthur thing and I was ready
to I was ready to join up some kind of
an army that would go at act President
Truman that was a that was a terrible
fraught time in our history but as much
as you admire MacArthur the president
was correct and he was supported by all
of the Joint Chiefs we just can't have
this so MacArthur no doubt among the two
or three great ones in the last century
he's right there but a very complicated
person can I can I end with one funny
story the story I told you today he came
back to the United States there were
huge outpourings of welcome he gave a
famous and quite beautiful speech before
the joint session of Congress he was he
went through a long series of Senate
hearings with all of the other generals
and then he was made chairman of the
bulova Corporation and I think he was
handsomely compensated I don't think he
did a lot of work one day his wife was
much younger than he was Jean Faircloth
the tennessean called her friend up in
New York City they just got in there and
she said I I don't know anybody in the
city i'm sort of intimidated by it could
could you and I just go to a good
restaurant for lunch I don't even know
any restaurants and the friend said yes
there's a new Scottish restaurant which
is open here I'm anxious to take you
there McDonald's
and there's a new Scottish risk
restaurant thank you